as you'll likely be aware the United
States is one of the few countries in
the world that doesn't use the metric
system instead it uses U.S customary
measurements which is similar to the
imperial system used in Britain sort of
but given that the overwhelming majority
of Nations have adopted the metric
system this raises the question why
didn't the United States ever do the
same so as of American independence the
new nation unsurprisingly used the same
system of measurements as the British
and since the even after the war Britain
was still the United States main trading
partner it made sense to keep the system
to help facilitate trade George
Washington and Thomas Jefferson had
looked into adopting a new system in
1776 but given that they were you know
busy it wasn't a priority President
James Madison was a fan of the metric
system but when his use was abolished
across Europe in 1812 he and many others
believed that the system would die out
in the early 19th century the British
sought to standardize the measurement
system its Empire used and so it created
the imperial system which had some
differences to the units that Americans
used Britain had hoped that the United
States would adopt the Imperial systems
well but the Americans didn't fight and
win a war against the British just so
they could keep taking orders from them
so no as the United States continued to
grow as a chunk of international trade
many of its businesses started to trade
with more and more Nations these
countries used the metric system which
meant that U.S businesses were using
both as such to facilitate this into
lesson trade Reliance on Britain
President Andrew Johnson passed the
metric act which formalized conversion
rates and allowed businesses to use both
so did this formal recognition of the
metric system change anything well not
really as the 20th century approached
American feelings towards the metric
system hadn't changed however academic
and scientific communities pressured
successive presidents to adopt the
system but they were denied for three
primary reasons the first was that doing
so would require effort and nobody
wanted that the second was that the late
19th and early 20th centuries were a
fairly isolationist and patriotic period
and many Americans didn't want to adopt
the foreign metric system when they were
already using the American system the
argument was that other societies were
worse than America and they used the
metric system and thus by adopting it in
the United States it would only serve to
diminish the country the third reason
was that many policy makers are
manufacturing leaders in the United
States believed that it was an
inevitability that not only would
America rise to the top of the great
Powers but would eventually Eclipse them
all and so why go to the cost and effort
of replacing U.S customary measurements
when the rest of the world would
inevitably change for America this line
of thinking continued into the 1970s
this was when President Gerald R Ford
went the extra 169 meters in order to
swap the United States over to the
metric system first he passed a law
which placed the metric system as
America's Preferred system he and
Congress also established the metric
conversion board whose purpose was to
guide industry in the country into a
permanent adoption of the metric system
the problem was that the board couldn't
agree on how to adopt the system and
also nobody listened to it and when
Ronald Reagan took office in 1981 he
ended the board seeing its work as an
American and thereafter the attempts to
change to the metric system have been
unenthusiastic and unsuccessful meaning
that the United States would stay as one
of the few countries in the world that
didn't use the metric system I hope you
enjoyed this episode and a special
thanks to my patrons James bizzinette
Kelly moneymaker Sky Chappelle Corsa
wolf Jerry lambden Jordan Longley Adam
Stalter Marcus Arsenal Y in hockey
Spencer Lightfoot rod D Martin words
about books podcast Captain side dog
Gustav Swan Marvin Castle commune
Winston K wood boogly Wiggly Daniel to
be in Miss is it Aaron the white Corey
Turner the makwapa Alex Schwinn Anthony
Beckett Coppertone Maggie Paskowski she
went in spinning three plates and
Charles the first